foreign
[Music]
let's get this show on the road
one two three roll the cameras black
against even good
from Australia
E4 great
and now the big question will we finally
get an open Sicilian still we won't get
it open so we get an elephant with black
which I really like because
I play the elephant with white that's my
speedrun recommendation and one of my
biggest pet peeves
is when
you know someone recommends an opening
and then pretends that that opening wins
by force the elephant is not win by
force black has several ways to achieve
comfortable equality against the
elephant but black has to know a lot and
the line that I'm going to trot out in
this game
is a line that I really like for two
reasons It's relatively unknown
uh three reasons black actually fights
for the advantage so you're not just
trying to beg for equality if white
misplays that black is better
and it's relatively sound white can get
a slight Advantage but white has to know
a great deal of theory and it's one of
those lines that slips through the
cracks like I I don't see it discussed
in too many places I think a book came
out by lock dewala that covers it
recently but that's the only thing I
know you start with the move D5 which is
the one of the two main moves but after
he takes D5 you don't recapture with the
queen I assume I'm assuming our
opponent's gonna take there's no other
reasonable moves here with white yeah
and now we play this move Knight to F6
so it's sort of a Gambit
it's sort of a Gambit I mean it no it is
a Gambit white can keep the pawn with C4
but C4 is a very bad move here
um because black responds with E6 and we
get after the exchange a typical kind of
position that I've talked about
extensively across the various speedruns
and we reach that structure in several
different Sicilian positions and I'll
recap why black has overwhelming
compensation in that resulting position
after the game
foreign just write that down
okay Knight F3 so Knight F3 as far as I
know is not a bad move but it's not the
best not a challenging move and of
course what is the purp what is the
point of playing Knight episode why are
we not taking back with the queen well
the point is pretty obvious we're trying
to take back with the Knight which is a
more convenient way of taking back the
pawn we keep our Queen on its initial
Square so that the queen does not become
vulnerable to various attacks so we
recapture with the Knight that's the
whole point of the line
and I'm assuming that our opponent is
going to go Bishop C4 okay this I'm not
too familiar with and I don't think it's
the best way for white to play
so our opponent is developing pieces and
putting pressure on the Knight
but here I think we have a nice
elegant way to resolve
the tension in the center it's it's a
typical type of move that you find in
response to Bishop C4 in many different
openings actually you should just be
familiar with this move
because this move achieves a lot does
anybody know what I'm talking about
so 96 E6 is fine but I don't want to
close off the bishop just yet so of
course you can play Knight to C6
but then white could respond with D4 the
move I'm talking about is actually
Knight to B6
and you might say well why
step back with the Knight I mean isn't
the point to keep the knight in the
center not really by stepping back with
the Knight we're forcing this bishop to
commit
and the main reason we bring the Knight
back to B6 is increasing our control
over the D4 square right by moving the
Knight back we open up contact that our
Queen now makes with the D4 Square what
are we preparing for we are preparing
ultimately for an isolated Queen Pawn
structure which is going to happen if
white plays the move d4
then we take on D4 and in the elephant
mostly white takes back so
what's important in an isolated Queen
Pawn structure it's control of the
square in front of the pawn as I've
explained many times
and by bringing the Knight back we are
expanding our control over the D5 Square
now what we don't want to do here with
black we do not want to play Bishop to
G4 that falls victim to the typical
tactic Bishop takes F7 check King F7 and
then the Knight jumps out winning the
bishop back
there are several cool things that we
could do here but I really like the
concept of developing the bishop to F5
because we want to go E6 here at some
point but we don't want to block out the
bishop if possible
so I I like the notion of going Bishop
F5 and there is a reason that I don't
want to go Knight C6 first if you can
Envision in your head after Knight C6
white plays D4
so let's say we trade on D4 and then if
we go Bishop F5 there
who can tell me what nasty move we are
walking into in that particular version
of development
like overly nasty but I don't see a
reason to allow it yeah well I can play
D5
and we don't have a Pawn on E6 yet so
what I really like here is get the
bishop out first then play E6 and then
only develop the B8 Knight later
establish control over the D5 Square
first then later you can bring the
Knight out to C6
another positive benefit of Bishop F5 is
that it
well it doesn't Force white to play D4
but it really
encourages it because if white doesn't
play D4 we can actually stick the bishop
on D3 potentially and create the bind on
the light squares which is going to make
it very hard for white to bring the
queen side out so it's a challenging
move
castles okay well our opponent is giving
us the option of playing Bishop D3
so let's consider it Bishop D3
from a development standpoint Bishop D3
is a risky move because we're not
developing or we're sending the Rook to
the open file so let's consider Bishop
D3 rookie one
then we maybe bring our Knight out to C6
it's interesting
I don't see anything
clearly wrong with it but of course the
conservative move is just E6 so we can
play very ambitiously here with Bishops
E3
we could play conservatively with E6 and
then likely white plays D4 and then we
bring our Knight out and we get a normal
position so E6 is the chill move Bishop
D3 is the like
you know
I am trying to be Alpha type of move but
in the speedrun we try to be Alpha and
we try to punish our opponent for
opening imprecisions
and so I think we're gonna go for the
well no Bishop D3 is a tactical flaw
actually ooh this is very pretty I just
spotted something that's wrong with
Bishop D3
and it's not Bishop takes F7 check I
know some of you are thinking that
because after King takes Bishop why does
this one check on E5 the king can move
back to G8 and the queen defends the
bishop after Bishop D3 there is the
immediate 95.
threatening Checkmate on F7
and attacking the bishop not really
attacking the bishop but you don't want
to give that Bishop away because then
white can drop the bishop back to C2 and
kick the queen back
so
this is kind of a cool detail and so
we don't want to make an unsound move
even though our opponent might not spot
Knight E5
let's go E6 you considered it we refuted
it it's okay
we go with the conventional approach
I'm expecting D4 playing
as white without D4 makes no sense
Knight H4 no Knight H4 blunders the
Knight
C4
well C4 for white is a terrible
positional move
so that just gives up the entire Center
I mean the White's never getting his
Queen side out then
okay D4 played
so here a nice little detail I think a
lot of people would automatically take
that pawn
but that's an inaccuracy why why is
taking the pawn an inaccuracy well it's
because white can take back with the
Knight
why is that dangerous well taking back
with a knight is very annoying for us
because it hits the bishop on F5 we have
to move the bishop back to G6
and
in that resulting situation I feel like
I can bring the queen out to F3
attacking B7 and we get punished for
neglecting our Queen side development so
these types of subtleties as we enter
the 16 1700s like I'm talking about like
the century these types of subtleties
become very important and they're not
particularly hard to understand but you
just have to be careful so it's better
to to start with the Knight C6 are we
afraid of DC obviously not we can just
take back with the bishop and if white
wants to trade Queens you know be my
guest give us the D file we have a great
end game
so there's no hurry to play CD I mean
now CD makes more sense because Knight
takes D4
we can just play Knight takes D4
also yeah as Vince Vance points out
as long as the pawn remains on C3 this
is one of the drawbacks of the elephant
the Knight on B1 lacks a comfortable
developing Square
so there is a case to be made for
keeping this tension as long as possible
and actually just going Bishop E7
castles we also know that tension makes
players uncomfortable so
you should default on the side of
keeping Pawn tension because that often
causes players to make irrational
decisions
ofas asks is Queen to c7a move yeah
Queen C7 is potentially possible but I
wouldn't play it here because we're
x-rayed
we're x-rayed and white actually
threatens the move D5
D5 is a very dangerous threat because
Knight takes D5 Bishop takes D5
Queen D5 Queen but we cannot take back
with a pawn or x-ray so how should we
respond to this x-ray
one should respond by developing our
Bishop this doesn't change our plan so
Bishop B7 breaks the X-ray develops the
bishop prepares to Castle
I Don't Like Queenie Queen C7 neglects
C5 although maybe you can long Castle
there that's a that's actually a very
creative idea oh
that would have been very interesting
Queen C7 and if D5 then we long castle
and white can't take the Knight because
the queen is pinned
but okay Bishop B7 is
standard and there's nothing wrong with
that okay we've got a good position here
yeah G6 would be very bad
way too slow and creates dark square
holes no G6 is terrible in this position
okay lost in the woods as why did we not
trade on D4 well I did explain that just
now now you might be wondering why we
didn't trade here and the reason is that
we give the Knight the C3 Square
and there's no downside to not trading
on D4 we can basically do it we want to
Bishop E3 okay our opponent is playing
this very well
let's think here this is an important
position
so the natural well first of all it's
important to realize that white is
actually threatening to take the pawn on
C5 that is not a pawn we want to just
give away so castling here is is a bad
move blunder's Bond
so the natural reaction would be to play
CD no CD is a decent move but again in
addition to white recapturing with a
pawn notice that white can actually
recapture with the Knight
and if we trade the bishop gets to D4
that's a nicely centralized Bishop it's
hitting G7
and our position is still very solid
there but so is whites
and ideally I'd like to play something
with a little bit more Pizzazz and there
is a move here that contains quite a bit
of pizzazz
it's a hard move to play though it's
it's kind of a hard move to find but
dark tiger
has found it
so not C4 I don't like C4 because then
it allows white to create a big
stronghold on D4
I'm talking about the move Knight to D5
which we're gonna play
and it's one of those moves like once I
play it you should fully understand why
it's played technically we're sacking
upon by the way this was a pawn sack
um
but I have a feeling that it's Justified
so
what is the purpose of this move well
it's simple if white plays DC
then we eliminate the bishop on E3 and
then we recapture on C5
if white takes the Knight then we take
back with our Queen we get the bishop
pair
now why is it a pawn sec
how can white actually accept the
sacrifice
who can tell me
it is upon set Knight D5 is a pawn sack
takes takes
yeah and then DC exactly takes takes DC
and if you visualize that position if we
take back on
C5 then white takes the queen first and
then takes our Bishop so we can't do
that
and after DC if we take the queen then
we can no longer take back on C5
but I saw this
and I would classify this as a little
bit dubious for black but potentially
very rewarding if white is not Ultra
accurate
okay our opponent
trusts us Knight A3 so you can tell this
is a real elephant player
so he sees he knows about Knight A3 the
Knight A3 here has lost a lot of its
luster because we're so well developed
that this idea can be pretty easily
buried
so
what should we do here I think we should
take on D4 I think the time is for us
has come to take on D4
why not A6 because after A6 then white
can take on C5
and I'll show you after the game why
that ending is really bad for black
while the position after DC here I think
is quite Justified for black there's a
big difference
and I'll delve into that after the game
but what I'll say for now is that
because white is now well developed DC
has become a more serious problem
if we Castle we do not address DC White
can still play DC and win the pawn
the great thing about CD is that it also
stops Knight B5 so I think the time has
come to release the tension CD
we're also now aiming at the Knight with
our Bishop so we can play Bishop takes
A3 ruining White's Queen Side Pawn
structure
the downside of that move is that we
give up our Bishop pair and I'm not sure
we want opposite colored Bishops creates
a lot of drawers potential
so we're playing very simple chests here
but the position is going to get
complicated I'm assuming our opponent is
going to take back with a knight which
would be correct a very bad move here
for white would be to take with a pawn
that would give us exactly what we want
it would give us
like the ideal iqp setup with the bishop
pair and a queen and a block getting
Square okay Knight D4
so let me think for a couple moments
here because we've got several
alternatives
okay yeah there are many ways to play
this
and all of them are pretty good I think
so
I'm curious what what people come up
with in this type of position
the instinct is for me to ignore right
you have a bunch of stuff going on but
white doesn't actually really have any
threats okay white is quote unquote
threatening to get rid of our Bishop
pair but that's not worth crying over
because we can take back with a queen
and our remaining minor pieces are
superior to what to whites I mean the
Knight is bad the bishop on E3 is kind
of awkward
and we can get control of the D file
later
so we can Castle King's side and we can
Castle Queen side and both moves make
sense I do not like castling Queen side
I think that's way too dubious gasoline
Queen side I think the White Queen could
come out to A4 the Knight could come out
to be 5y why would we seek that you know
those Adventures so let's be solid and
Castle the other way Castle's King side
I mean white can play Knight B5 but that
is totally innocuous it's one movitus it
just threatens an easy threat to Perry
Knight B5 we can even play Knight takes
D4 if we wanted to
and Knight C7 there would not work as
I'll show after the game
jot that down
the position is dry yeah the position is
very dry I think we are slightly better
but knowing how to play these types of
positions is crucial you have to know
how to outplay people from these
toothless boring
positions where neither side has any
weaknesses
I think the only reason we're a little
bit better is because
we've got slightly better placement of
our minor pieces Our Queen is active
but that's the only reason
and white should be able to maintain the
balance with accurate play
so it's very Josh
there's no imbalance
and hopefully I mean I can't guarantee
that we'll win this game but
how do you outplay people from this
position
well first of all we need to see what
white does because white can do a lot of
different things here
and our next move is likely to be Rick
after gate I'm also eyeing Bishop takes
A3 because here Bishop takes A3 creates
a piece imbalance and I'm more happy
with that than with opposite colored
Bishops I'd be more than happy to have a
good night against a bad Bishop okay
Knight C2
cool
so
Rook d8 is the obvious move the queen
will come up to E2 there though and then
white can contest the D file direct D1
that sends the game further into a very
drawish Avenue
so again ideally we'd find something
that unbalances the position a little
bit more causes
slightly more
difficulties you need to be able to ask
some questions here and get people to
make mistakes
so I have an interesting idea
I have an interesting idea
and I'm just going to play this move and
then I'll explain it properly after the
game yeah very good I mean Don
Brilliance actually
pointed this move out Queen B5
now obviously we're threatening the pawn
on B2 and I think a lot of people
would see this move and just say well
what's so great about attacking the pawn
well nothing I mean I don't think this
move wins the game or anything but we're
just starting to ask white some
questions and we're of course trying to
provoke some weaknesses on the queen
side that's our ultimate goal so ideally
we're trying to provoke the move B3
why is V3 a weakening move well B3
weakens the neighboring Pawn on C3 and
that pawn is very easy to attack we can
bring our Bishop up
to the long diagonal
and then
you know the dominoes start to fall on
the queen side
so B3 is a bad move Rogue B1 ties The
Rook down to the defense of the pawn
that seems to have positive development
for us
and it's actually not so easy for white
to defend that pawn in a convenient way
if you look at this very carefully
you might say well what about Queen C1
well then we can put a rook on d8 and
white has closed off the other Rook
yeah Queen D2 is possible but then again
we can tickle the queen with Rook fd8
Queen D2 is a very tricky move we don't
want to take as we get our Queen trapped
but
Queen D2 walks right into Rook fd8
Queen B1 well that's awkward
I'd love to see Queen B1
so hopefully you're you're you're seeing
that this move is annoying it's an
annoying move Queen G4 okay
I think our opponent panics
just classic our opponent is completely
panicked
I have no idea what he intends on Queen
takes B2
because it should be obvious to you that
Bishop H6
can be met with Bishop to F6 something
people forget actually a lot which is
that this construction with the queen
and the bishop
people tend to assume that G6 is forced
and that you lose the exchange but it's
not there are many ways to defend the G7
Pawn
I'll show you another example of this
after the game
but Queen takes B2 is
winning I mean we just win the queen
side
and the game
but do you see how quickly players tend
to panic when you when you pose a
dilemma like that
yeah very good Bishop F6 Queen takes
Pawn also defends G7 and that's the best
move
good eye
very good eye
now white needs to
you know back pedal with like Knight C4
but
this is already very bad
this is not GGI exaggerated obviously
the game is far from over
but it's losing objectively
it's losing objectively
what's the rough eval here if I had to
say a number and people watching on
YouTube are probably going to pause the
video and like check
on stockfish I would estimate minus two
maybe I'm also not very good at computer
assessments but I'd estimate minus two
or like minus 1.7 so like basically lost
okay Knight D4 good job by our opponent
to keep his composure
I don't see a single compelling reason
why we cannot help ourselves to another
juicy Pawn on the queen side
we should not take the Knight first
because then the bishop recaptures and
not only does white defense see through
but also threads mate
so
I mean I don't see there's no threat on
G7
Knight takes E6 does nothing
I mean white can attack the queen but
big freaking deal the queen can move
anywhere
yeah this is this is borderline over
so Knight D4 actually might have been
another mistake I don't know how white
should have played there
yeah nice bonus move
is Queen steps back to B4 pinning the
Knight
so the Knight can take but then we win
the queen on G4
okay Rook ac1
Queen to B4 Knight takes C6 Queen takes
Queen Knight takes E7 check
King has h8
and we win so against Queen before I am
assuming our opponent is intending Rook
back to B1
in order to Target B7
so let's calculate Queen B4 Rook B1 what
do we have
on tap in that position
well we have a very Advanced tactical
idea there
what should we do in that position
very good Queen to A4
why Queen A4 don't worry about B7
well after we give up B7 we could drive
our Bishop up to F6 and the Knight is
going to be lost
because of the power of the pin against
the queen we just pile up on the night
with everything we got and we got a lot
of ways to do that we don't even need
all those moves and the night is going
to be lost easy calculation
Bang
yeah the alternative here the simpler
move would be Queen back to A5
and notice that we have a contact with
the Rook on E1 so white would not be
able to capture twice but Queen before
we are going for more than just two
Pawns
so let's finish this game off
let's finish this game off
how do we finish it off
yeah E5 I think E5 works I'm just
checking
we have a four
E5 Knight takes C6 Queen takes Queen
we just need to double check because
there's a lot going on E5 Bishop H6
actually exists
E5 Bishop H6 but then Bishop F6
and that position is you know you have
to be careful there but it works because
anytime Our Queen is attacked we can
step away to A4 the presence of the A4
square is really important here
otherwise if white would have been able
to dislodge Our Queen from the PIN
then the Knight would have been able to
jump into F5 causing huge problems to
our King
but it's one of those things where you
actually have to be very accurate the
margin of error is Slim
but I believe E5 wins
and by the way Knight takes Knight the
reason I
spelled that out is because there are
situations I'm sure you've seen where
it's like oh the Knight takes another
piece
and like the queen is forked or
something
or it's me I mean the king it literally
has one square in the corner
but you have to calculate that
foreign
what about getting our Rooks into play
well we have bigger fish to fry we're
winning a night forget about our Rooks
our Rooks can wait
yeah it's resignable I think it's
resignable I mean I if I were playing
white I would try Bishop H6
Force our opponent to find Bishop F6 and
then play Rook B1 and after Queen A4 I
would resign
goes for A3 by the way doesn't change
anything Queen A4
yeah look out how much I mean we played
Queen B5 four moves ago
that is staggering this position and
this position occurred four moves apart
so this kind of worked to Perfection
this is what I was really hoping would
happen because it's a good illustration
of the power of these annoying threats
yeah now our proponent is is obviously
searching for
resources but there are none to be found
where it's just too
well it's just crumbling here
Bishop D2 okay well this
we can just take the knights straight
away I think we don't even need to play
we can play Queen A4 that would that
does not hurt
but
we can just grab the Knight because the
Rook blocks the bishop and there's
obviously no discoveries I mean Bishop
H6 here we also are attacking the queen
so that does not work
and now we're up a piece in two pawns
the rest is just a matter of realizing
our advantage
Queen G3 okay so our work is not done
in fact it's very easy to blunder here
really easy to blunder here Bishop H6
is a game-winning threat if we allow it
and we lose the queen because there's no
way to stop made and defend the queen at
the same time
so the
you know straightforward move is to move
the queen out of the way Queen E4 Queen
A4
but if we want to be fancy
then we can also exploit the weak back
Rank and Parry the threat actively what
am I talking about
yeah Bishop H4 also very good move
actually
but I like them of Rook a to d8
Bishop H6 obviously you have Queen takes
a rook Rook takes Rook Rook takes Rook
mate because white does not have left
so
and this is a good move because it
brings The Rook into the game
so it hastens White's defeat
why Rook a and not Rook f it does not
matter at all
does not matter at all I mean in this
case either way works
but this is just like the default I
don't know Rook 80 so that the other row
can go to E8
doesn't matter though
yeah if you do your puzzle rush you just
okay H3 so obviously now White
reinforces
the threat of Bishop H6 it's time to
respond to it more directly
foreign
we have a choice I would say one option
is to move the queen away
the other option is to address the
threat directly by sending White's Queen
away
I like Bishop H4 everybody's suggesting
it it's a direct move
it just forces the Queen off of the G
file
doesn't win the game on the spot why
does Queen F3
then we can continue the torture with E4
if we want to
yeah Bishop F6 ah Bishop FC there's
Bishop G5
you don't want to play with fire you
don't want to like unnecessarily allow
these discoveries if you can avoid it at
all I wouldn't keep the queen on D4 even
if it technically would work
okay Queen B3 is a blunder we take F2
and then we take the bishop and we win
I think white resigns here
and we hit 1700 on the nose
with this game
and I'll share a little bit of theory in
the b in the D5 variation
just so people have a you know already a
weapon against the album H1
we obviously take this bishop over here
[Music]
and easy clap Queen takes D2
it's over
Red Rover
the term wrong Rook comes up in some old
chess book but isn't always explained
yeah the question of which Rook to put
on a certain Square
I was thinking of doing in my like next
week like a chapter just on that
question
but people make too big of a deal out of
that concept it really is not a game
defining question in most
at most levels
and it's often easier to decide which
Rook to put on a square than you realize
and most of the time you have to decide
intuitively it doesn't have to do with
calculation it has to do with what you
think the other Rook is going to be
doing and what you think the other Rook
should be doing let's move the queen
away where should we move it anywhere
E2 is good keep contact with the Rook
Knight D4 coming in next
we don't even need our Rook right now
we're just using our miners
many ways to win this position easiest
is to try to force a queen trade that'll
make it very straightforward
yeah Rook d8 to trade is fine
as I always say when we get these super
overwhelming positions we're up a
thousand pieces
don't just sort of panic when I'm not
playing your move
there's like 50 different ways to
convert this I like Knight D4 because it
does it it encourages the queen trade
but it also sets up mating a potential
mating attack
yeah there's an interesting concept
called mysterious Rook moves I don't
remember who coined this phrase I think
it was nimsovich actually
and it refers to like a stereotypical
Grandmaster I did a lecture on
mysterious I wrote an article on them
actually for chess.com a while back
and they refer to like Rook moves that
move the Rook to like a closed file it's
like the stereotypical GM move that
people are like I won't understand that
move
but if you look more carefully it can
always be understood
okay let's finish right off
I think we need our Rook to finish right
off
so
I like the prospect of bringing the Rook
to C2
yeah rookdale Knight F3 also works but
the king can step away
so I don't love that we're playing
without Luft by the way
so
if you're at a beginner level and you're
watching this game
a good idea if you're a beginner and
you're up two three pieces is play a
move like G6 here play I move like H5
because you essentially put the training
wheels on you ensure that you you make a
blunder safe mechanism
so it only costs one tempo and it just
ensures that you don't blunder a back
rank mate somewhere
but because we're playing to our level
here we can safely play without Luft
because white doesn't have access to the
back rank
just making sure that Rook C2 Works no
there's no Queen B8 there's a pawn here
actually wait a second this is funny
Rook C2 there's Queen takes B7
oh we have a sexy mate there let's do it
oh man this is nice who sees the mate
who sees the maid
Queen takes B7 puzzle Rush
not Queen takes G2 come on Queen G2
that's the point of Queen takes B7 it
defends
no not Knight check Queen takes the
Knight that's a deflection attempt it
doesn't work
Queen F1 very good Queen F1
King F1 Rook C1 back ranker
because the bishop defends one square in
the second Rank and the Knight defends
the other
would be nice if we finish the game in
that way
Bang
and if you're looking at this and saying
well I would never spot a mate like this
well that's not true
because doing puzzle Rush literally
allows you to find mates like this
quickly
there's no I feel like the equivalent is
like
you know nine times seven sixty three
how did you solve that so quickly like I
there's no answer there's no process
that you followed to find these types of
moves you just have to develop the
pattern recognition
and you have to be patient with yourself
that it will come if you do enough
puzzles period okay let's go over the
game
yes so this line with Knight F6
I remember like I faced it I used to I
mean I played the elephant full time
when I was like I faced it when I was
1700 once and I had no idea what to do
and said I was just worse
and I lost and ever since then it's been
on my radar
um and it's and it's really underrated
so a couple of lines to know here
um
first and foremost what happens if white
defends the pawn with C4
well blackley's E6 we need to get rid of
this Pawn on D5 in order to unlock the
compensation so we play E6
okay
white has to take on E6
then we take back with the bishop and
we've had this exact type of position
before in a slightly different Line This
is an improved version for white but
White's position practically speaking is
still not very appealing after Knight C6
because we've got control over the
square making it very hard for a white
to get his pieces out
where have we had this similar idea we
faced the move F4 a couple of times
and you might remember that the proper
response is D5 you actually do the same
thing takes the Knight F6 similar
concept and if I play C4 we have
literally had this position in the
speedrun before this is even worse for
white because this Pawn is sticking out
like a sore thumb but it's the same
principles apply
so if we
get the position through this line
well for instance Knight F3 Knight C6
you've got great development you've got
central control
there's like 30 games in the database or
so I mean some GMS have played this with
white Bishop D7
and
I like
the engine recommendation here which is
actually Queen to C7
and this is a very nice move because if
white plays D4
then you play CD
Knight D4 and you win the game by
castling
creating
that's it the game is over
the Knight is lost
so Queen C7 is a very tricky move and
you make space for The Rook to get to d8
a common type of idea for example white
let's say castles
and now you can actually Castle Queen
side which I quite like because you've
got a big development advantage and
you've got
you know serious Prospect of of King
side attack
after Knight C3 it is important to play
A6 here
because you don't want to rush Bishop D6
and walk into Knight B5
you want to throw an A6 then Bishop D6
and then just run your pawns off the
board and check May white on the king
side practically this is very bad for
white even if the engine gives like a
slight Edge you don't care you can also
go H5 and Knight G4 and try to get to H2
you've got an id4
this is really really bad for white
so C4 is
not problematic
what are the other moves for white white
can play D4
and just continue as if nothing's the
matter
and here as far as I remember the move
is Knight takes D5
allowing white to play DC
but now you're able to win this Pawn
back pretty straightforwardly with the
move E6
and here what black is doing completely
fine
I'm in this position
because if white plays B4 and tries to
cling to the pawn
well you have a very typical way to
respond you want to attack the base of
the pawn chain with A5 and White's Queen
side crumbles if a three then you and
then you play Knife Knight takes before
you don't mind the queen trade white is
lost here can't take the Knight because
the Rook hangs this hangs this hangs oh
it's
getting squashed here
so that doesn't cut it after E6 white
can play C4 this looks scary because you
have to move the Knight but that's okay
you move the Knight back you don't mind
getting the king out to d8 because
you've got a development advantage
and if y Place Bishop to E3
the Knight can further hop into G4
dislodging the Bishop from the its
defense of the pawn
Bishop D4 Knight comes out to C6
and then if y plays Knight F3 then you
can push well you can you don't have to
take and take and you win the game
because white also loses F2 so
everywhere you look Black's got some
punch to his play again if before you
always have A5
and the queen side collapses for white
otherwise you take on C5 the king can be
stored on E7 and you've got a great
position you can feed and get a light
squared Bishop I like this end game for
black
so this is quite good for black as well
95 Knight F3 is a line and we'll look at
this in the game continuation move order
this can transpose to what could have
happened in the game had a way to play
D4 quickly
so
the best move in this position for for
white is Bishop to B5 check
another important idea to keep in your
pocket you're forcing a piece to appear
on D7
essentially cutting the contact between
the queen and the pawn
the best move for right here is NB to D7
ibd7
still threatening to take on T5
and one of the main lines goes D4
and now you have to know this move A6
chasing the bishop things get a little
complicated here I don't want to do too
much Theory so I'll just limit myself to
like one or two lines here
if white takes the Knight
and you take back with the queen
and if white takes DC again you have to
be comfortable playing down a pawn for a
while what you should understand is that
you've got the bishop pair and you're
gonna probably win the pawn on C5 back
pretty quickly because again after
Knight F3 you already play second you
know the drill if before again you play
A5 it's like the same thing over and
over and over again
so this is not worrisome
the engine move here after A6
is actually Bishop back to E2 this is
not an easy move for
humans to find take back on D5
and white is just supposed to keep
developing and so do you E6 in this
position is equal I don't think White's
got anything here castles
and then there's B5 but I like the move
Queen out to C7
allowing for the Knight to jump to F4
very solid position for black and this
is unique so elephant players are going
to be uncomfortable here
so that's another line there's also
Queen A4 check which I won't get into
right now you can look at this on your
own the move here is also nbd7
and this is a sharp line but black is
doing fine here as well
so white is able to get a slight
Advantage here as far as I know
with the move I actually don't know what
the best move is according to Modern
well the engine move is Queen A4 check
and bd7
this is very uncommon by the way
and now at least at a low depth okay the
engine gives C4
and the point is if you play E6 here
then white takes and you can't take back
with the bishop you have to play the
awkward Fe
so here stockfish gives the incredible
B5 sacrificing a second Pawn
but getting a huge development Advantage
you get the Rook into the game
then you play E6
and this position is very dangerous for
white it's plus equals white is better
according to the engine
but you're getting your pieces out so
fast the point of B5 is also that you're
vacating the fianchetto for the bishop
why could why could lose control over
the position really quickly
Knight F3 Bishop D6
for example D3 you Castle you also have
the f file this is super fun to play
Bishop B2 Bishop B Center look at
Black's pieces here
and if White Castles
then you're already winning after Knight
G4 Black's attack crashes through
H3
you take the Knight and you drop the
Knight into H2 typical Motif forking the
rook and the bishop wipe right off the
board
so you can dig around here on your own
but this is why I love this line it's
like super sharp and you can play for an
advantage for with black there is also
Queen to B3 in this position
engine move
and as far as I know you're supposed to
play A6 with black to prepare B5 and
Bishop B7
and if white plays A4 you bring the
queen out
Knight F3
and you have this move Knight to E5
the point of playing A6 is also that you
prevent the check on B5
um and if white plays Knight takes E5
you take back with the queen pick up D5
and if Bishop B2 you drive the pawn into
C4
and then you actually give up another
Pawn
you give it no no you take and then you
throw in the check and then this comes
out and the bishop gets to D3 with check
and white is losing so everywhere you
look there are lines like this
and what I would recommend is that you
you know look at these lines carefully
but also
do 10 15 minutes of your own analysis
so look at stuff that you find to be
reasonable but this is just a broad
overview
so Knight F3 Knight C5 is the game
continuation and I think our opponent
played a decent move but one that
doesn't test this at all
if white plays D4 here
then the move for black is just a moment
the move for black is CD we we take on
D4
and if white plays CD
then this
plays right into our hands we get an iqp
position with our Knight perfectly
placed on D5 here I like the move G6
here we can afford the luxury
of fee and ketoing our dark card Bishop
because white is so passive here
and if Bishop C4 then we
take on C3 and go Queen C7 x-raying the
pawn on C3 we have a great position
black is better
so white of course should not take with
the pawn white should take with
probably the Knight fight takes to the
queen then we have Knight C6 that
doesn't make sense so Knight T4
and here we can go Knight C6
um
but we can also play the move E5 this is
the ambitious move
and if the Knight drops back
then we develop our Knight to C6 Bishop
B5
and we protect the E5 Pawn we are not
afraid
to play the move F6 here
why are we not afraid to play F6 because
we can drop our Knight back to C7
offering the queen trade and if white
accepted black is an excellent end game
we we have perfect central control the
bishop comes out to E6 and the Knight is
very much restricted we're covering the
D4 Square
this check is innocuous big deal just
move the king away
black is doing great here so
this is also not dangerous
where our opponent played gave us
I think an excellent position we go
Knight B6
and
there's a couple of things to note
so to reiterate
why did we not play Knight C6 first well
it's because after D4
this position occurs
and
if we play Bishop F5 we allow the extra
very nasty option of D5 don't want to
allow this at all
if we play E6 then which is not bad but
we Block in the bishop and we want
everything
so that's why we bring the bishop out
first a little subtlety then we play E6
and only then do we go Knight C6 now D5
is impossible
okay rookie one Bishop E7
Bishop E3 and Knight D5 and definitely I
think our opponent
in this position played a very
inaccurate I think after Knight A3 we
are we've got a great position
I was going to address
why
well okay I don't even need to address
this everybody should fin ketoing here
makes zeros I mean G6 just looks
horrible here
I mean you're just walking into like a
gazillion things now you can't go G6
here it's too slow
no no you got to go Bishop E7
so what should white have have done here
white should have accepted the SEC
and here
I was planning to play the move Rook to
d8
or a long Castle
leading directly to this end game which
I thought was very interesting
because we are threatening to win the
pawn back with Bishop takes C5
and if white protects it
then we can bring the bishop out to F6
and just look at the pressure that we
are exerting on white I mean just look
at our pieces our pieces are amazing
so clearly black has excellent
compensation but the engine actually
gives Knight bd2
and this is where you know when you just
analyze with the engine you you get an
you get the wrong impression of of your
play you often get the impression that
you played horribly but Knight bd2 is a
very hard move to find
because here you have to see what who
can spot why Bishop C5 fails
it's not impossible but what what is the
point here who sees it
foreign
no but you have to be able to give the
pawn yeah C4 wins C4 wins the game
because the Rook has nowhere to go to
keep the bishop protected
so when I say it it's easy but actually
finding it is hard
but we would not have taken on C5
obviously and the engine according to
the engine we're supposed to play A5
to prevent because now B4 already
becomes a problem
and for and white has actually no good
improving moves
yeah white it's equal the position is
equal
if white plays Knight C4 then we take
take check here oh this is sexy takes we
trap the Knight
trap the knife so this is equal
I mean you can offer a draw here black
may be a little bit better
so yeah so this is a Justified Pawn
sacrifice
but definitely white should have gone
for this position when our opponent goes
Knight A3 he hangs he hands over
the advantage C takes D4
Knight D4 castles and we reach
a position that I think is equal
if white is careful but definitely I
would choose black any day like I think
practically it's harder to play for
white
and the key moment in the game and I
actually this is the top engine move
Queen B5 so it's not just a gimmicky one
move thread it is the top move this is
the game-winning move Queen to B5
it's this ability to pose force your
opponent to make decisions
so why is this annoying well if white
plays B3 we were planning Bishop F6
and some of you were wondering what
happens if C4 well if C4
then black
gets the long diagonal we went upon
simply Queen A6 the game is not over but
white is collapsing
The Rook hangs
and we can safely grab the pawn the
queen is unattackable
and we're up a pawn Rook is coming to
D.A this is great
and as I was indicating Rook B1 is not a
move that people want to play even
though it's the only the best move
here we would go Rook d8 either Rook
and we would grab the D file
and we're in great shape well B4 is even
worse than B3 because this Pawn's even
weaker
here definitely Bishop F6 and the queen
can drive into C4
so this is this is just terrible for
white
so the way white should have played here
according to the computer is Queen C1
but we we again can bring the bishop to
F6 or we can even go 95 and try to go
Knight T3
white has to see a bunch of details like
Knight D4
and then white can bring the queen up to
C2
but then we go Knight C4 so it's like
it's unpleasant for white We're
pressuring White's Queen side here
so hopefully the move makes sense trying
to provoke weaknesses Queen B5
our opponent just collapses Queen G4
Queen B2
and
you know white loses everything here we
take another Pawn
and very importantly after Rook C1 we
have the game-winning move Queen to B4
pinning the Knight
and what I'll mention is that after Rook
B1 we had Queen A4
Rook takes B7 and now Bishop to F6 with
a similar outcome as in the game where
the Knight is simply lost
bang bang
that's it the Knight is lost on D4
so I don't know
what is the best that white could have
done here I don't care it doesn't matter
white is already losing
um one of the key takeaways for
particularly for newer players is that
this Construction
does not force you to play G6 there are
many ways to defend the pawn in many
cases
this
this and there is one other motif
that is important to put into your
mental database of ideas
and it is the following
well okay here's a good example actually
it's not exactly
common but I just remember this example
so in this position we have just traded
pieces on D4
and my opponent's in some trouble
because if she plays if she moves the
night back then E4 is lost so she plays
Bishop H6
obviously hopeful for G6
who can spot the winning move and
winning black wins on the spot here
really pretty
but why is 98 so good because white has
to move the Knight and who can spot the
follow-up
Bishop H4
sending the queen away
and then we win the bishop exactly so
the takeaway is that you shouldn't just
automatically play G6 you should
remember that there are many ways to
defend the spawn sometimes Knight H5
works here it doesn't because the bishop
defends but
you shouldn't in general react
automatically to certain ideas you
should always remember that there are
generally you know different defensive
methods so anyways I could expand on
this but this is what I have for now
and once white lost the queen side
well the rest was very straightforward
we win the night
and Rook idea was a pretty pretty move
obviously Bishop H6 we back rank made
white
the conversion was very straightforward
I think I explained everything during
the game
any questions
this was a simple game nothing no frills
I we learned a nice line against the
elephant so hopefully you enjoyed the
theoretical exposition
if you're watching on YouTube and you're
you're you know itching for more Theory
we'll get to it
um there's a lot of Chess left to be
played but you can always analyze on
your own
and and fill up your knowledge we're
doing things one step at a time
other takeaways the idea of
threatening a pawn and trying to force
the pawn up in order to create
weaknesses is more simple than it
appears it literally that's all there is
to it and and try to be annoying try to
force your opponent to make decisions
because decisions are stressful and
people panic
no there's no good move after Queen B5
like probably this or this is what white
should have played but look how
uncomfortable it is to play a move like
this
so moves like Queen B5 they don't cost
you anything
they don't sacrifice anything right so
it's a no-brainer to play a move like
this because you can always bring the
queen back if it doesn't work
but the effect is very powerful
white ends up panicking
and then we win all of his pieces in
like three moves
okay
I am exhausted I will go to bed
thanks Fran have a good
starts Wednesday see everybody later bye
foreign
[Music]